où est jolie ici c'est dans les halles
c'est super
[Musique]
le 1er mars 1969 le marché des Halles
qui était définitivement le quartier où
il se tenait depuis plus de huissiers la
fin des pavillons allait-elle signifiée
la mort du quartier peut-être pas une
nouvelle vague de commerçants brocanteur
restaurateur marchand d'art fripiers
s'installe tous les jours dans un
quartier que les anciens ne
reconnaissent plus pour les uns le
quartier René pour les autres il est
presque mort
[Musique]
l'as des innocents cet ancien mandataire
des Halles aujourd'hui installé à Rungis
n'a jamais voulu quitter son quartier
derrière nous à ce qui me concerne
personnellement
40 ans de notre vie mais en même temps
j'ai eu le sentiment que nous
accomplissions une mauvaise action car
le départ de la représentait une
conséquence économique et sociale très
importante
et je pense que après pas mal d'années
passées
ce problème se confirme que ce soit sur
le plan du quartier que ce soit avec les
habitants du quartier que ce soit aussi
avec entre
commerçant entre clients il y avait il y
avait il y avait vraiment un contact
nous ne savons pas exactement ce qui va
se passer ici on nous a pas demandé
votre avis
[Musique]
une des très nombreuses boutiques
transformées en grenier où l'on découvre
pêle-mêle chapeau de paille et robe de
partie de campagne une mode du passé
pour un quartier nouveau
[Musique]
chaussée de blanc
quand il devait voilà le printemps
il me conduit au Corée Du
vent tout enflant
nous sommes nous ici
[Musique]
Bruxelles
parmi les premiers à s'installer dans
cette rue
quelle idée au départ de venir
s'installer rue Saint-Denis par hasard
par des amis
les locaux intéressants les
loisissements les loyers étaient bons
marchés à l'époque les beaux
mais est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous aviez à l'époque idée de la
clientèle que vous avez trouvé
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors Monsieur Moreau qu'est-ce qui ne
va pas de quoi vous me parlez madame bah
de tout ce que vous avez envie de dire
sur votre quartier tout seul
racontez-nous un peu ce qui s'est passé
vu le commencement de déplacement des
Halles tout ça
ben c'était un coup dur pour moi
pourquoi ça s'est traduit par quoi pour
vous
traduis que j'ai perdu
il faut partir alors dans des cas
pareils
mais à mon âge c'est reconvertir
pourquoi faire et le passage est-ce que
la vie dans le passage
il y a 10 ans
c'était vivant
et tout ça c'est fini
toutes ces petites dames qui étaient là
maintenant les trois quarts ont disparu
tout le monde n'a pas le pessimisme de
Monsieur Moreau
c'était un enfant de 45 ans qui
voyageait seul avec sa grand-mère
voyageait seul avec sa maman je pense
que maintenant Saint-Germain est un
quartier complètement saturé
et les halles ça bouge beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de gens très bien qui habitent
au niveau des boutiques vraiment il y a
des choses
depuis deux mois
et avec vous dans votre univers on est
replongé 25 ans en arrière pourquoi
c'est une façon de vivre j'appelle ça
nostalgie
je crois que c'était une période où il y
avait beaucoup plus d'humour et beaucoup
plus de création que maintenant et quel
est votre clientèle
principalement étranger malheureusement
aussi pas du tout les gens du quartier
quelques quelques personnes de quartier
genre manuca illustrateur des gens qui
vivent aussi comme nous dans cette
époque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
découvert passage du Grand Cerf monsieur
Lory dernier fabricant à Paris de
bérébaque
[Musique]
depuis le départ des Halles c'est
complètement changé il y a des nouvelles
nouveaux commerces de nouvelles
boutiques
avec des beaucoup de jeunes maintenant
qui vendent des articles tout à fait
nouveau j'ai l'impression que le
quartier n'est plus pour vous n'est plus
à vous maintenant c'est la fin bientôt
pour nous autres
où est jolie ici c'est dans les halles
c'est superbe
[Musique]
nous sommes les moins chers de Paris
monsieur à l'heure actuelle le poulet à
4,90
si les habitants des Halles retrouvent
encore le pittoresque au marché
Montorgueil il en est d'autres expulsé
puis relogées qui ne croient plus en
l'avenir
quel effet ça vous a fait de voir votre
maison tombée
de la peine
moralement ça a été un choc
de quitter devenir ici
et alors la dernière vous êtes resté
dans une maison qui était déjà presque
morte et personne
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait après vous et
j'ai commencé
aussitôt que j'étais parti père et ils
ont enlevé les portes les fenêtres et
ils ont tous saccagé puis voilà vous
avez pas voulu aller voir oh non
et là le quartier qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ici ça ne change pas beaucoup de
nos quartiers mais c'est drôlement
changé vous savez
pierre et tout ça c'était merveilleux et
là vous vous y retrouvez plus
aujourd'hui ou non
n'a pas supporté le déménagement
[Musique]
toujours
de tous les de tous les immeubles
qui entoureront et entourant le forum
est prévu pour les années 1980 le forum
lui-même devant être mis en service en
même temps que le RER en 1978 on aura
successivement
les stations du RER à 28 mètres de
profondeur et au-dessus de ces stations
à notre niveau d'échange qui sera une
sorte de gigantesque salle des pas
perdue pendant les billets ou on
apprendra les correspondances qui sera
situé à moins à 17 mètres
encore on arrive dans le niveau dit
forum à -13 mètres qui est le premier
premier niveau commercial
largement ouvert au public dans ce
niveau on trouvera donc des commerces et
on pourra déjà
voir
la lumière naturelle c'est-à-dire la
place basse du forum située en plein
centre
[Musique]
grand-maman c'est New York je vois les
bateaux dans le port de New York dans le
quartier un certain nombre d'habitants
se sont posés le problème de savoir ce
qu'il en serait pour eux lorsque le
marché serait transféré
et il s'est créé une association qui est
devenue l'Union des Champeaux cette
association
comment dirais-je à organiser une
première exposition qui a eu pour but de
bloquer l'ensemble de l'aménagement du
quartier en passant si vous voulez d'une
surface de 35 hectares et 20 000
habitants expropriés à une surface de 15
hectares et 3000 habitants
[Musique]
dans 10 ans comment est-ce que vous
imaginez la vie au Halles bien dans 10
ans je l'imagine fort bien dans toute la
mesure où toutes les classes sociales
pourront s'y trouver représentées s'il
n'y a que des classes précises ou des
gens très riches ou des gens très
pauvres ou rien je crois je dirais
presque à la mort du quartier
[Musique]